this weekend was one of the greatest
fight sport
weekends in history yeah
uh Errol Spence Jr Terence bug Crawford
fight yeah for the unified 147 pound
Championship yeah
uh
uh just
out classes I mean yeah dude I was
rooting for Spence he's a Dallas guy
yeah I ordered the fight I'm watching
just to knock down after knockdown I'm
like what the [__] is it people said
it's one of the greatest fights matchups
ever if you want to look at both
undefeated yeah both undefeated both
incredibly dumb in their careers but if
you want to look at actual Elite boxing
skill yeah
you're not going to find another fight
like this I mean there's only a few in
history where both are elite elite
Fighters and tons of action that's the
thing that happens in a lot of like when
Elite Fighters fight each other a lot of
times it's not a lot of action because
both are so good they're canceling out
each of their advantages and it's like
okay maybe you're gonna get some strikes
maybe you're gonna get some touches but
it can be boring this was two guys that
were said I'm going to go after it I am
not running I'm not taking a step back
to Errol Spence Junior's credit he was
game till they stopped that fight yeah
he had no quit in him that guy is a
[__] dog like say whatever you want
about him getting beat and he got beat
convincingly he has [__] heart bro he
was going after it and he was he made
that fight interesting because it's easy
to step back and go okay I'm gonna try
to uh stick and and you use the jab get
on my bicycle move away not let this guy
touch me because he was getting that box
but he's like no I'm a dog I'm gonna get
in there I'm gonna throw these body
shots if I get caught get caught and he
did and then there's Bud Crawford and
all the credits of bud man that was an
unbelievable performance Elite boxing
never off balance not for a second every
punch he threw he was completely on
balance every time that he swung he was
within range his defense was impeccable
I mean this was one of the most glorious
boxing performers I've ever seen in my
entire life let me watch a boxing since
I'm a kid this man
it felt like I was watching Floyd like
it was just stylistically different but
the balance you never see Floyd off
balance yeah and you never saw Bud
reaching too far you never saw his
ability to throw with power every single
time the jab snapping yeah one of those
guys who's a uh he's a natural
right-handed dude but he fights Southpaw
so strong has his front Oscar de Hoya is
one of these guys that is you know great
but she's popping the jab and his
counters had always on balance it was
just beautiful this was like Immaculate
boxing if there was a way
to get people excited about boxing again
yeah it was watching this fight and it
was so interesting because we were
watching it at the casino in AC after
the show and thank you so much everybody
who came out to the show man that was
awesome
you were watching at the sport book and
you had the USC fight on and you had the
boxing match you had to watch both
that's great and you saw the energy
completely shift once the the the the
final card came on for the boxing yeah
once Arrow Spence and Bud Crawford were
fighting the energy of the whole sports
book was about the boxing match yeah
every fight before that in boxing nobody
gave a [__] about like nobody gave it
was all about the UFC I mean one of the
one of the things that Vala pointed this
out that like UFC really exposed
especially watching them side to side is
that when we were watching the pit bull
Cruise fight which is on the undercard
right shots of people cruise is an
excellent fire
um that fight went 12 rounds
three different UFC fights happened
within that 12 round fight yeah and each
of them were like ended a devastating
fashion and exciting it was like we just
got three
for the price of one yeah but in terms
of enjoyment we got 20 x enjoyments yeah
nobody even was looking at the boxing or
even cheering for the bot nothing and it
was just USC is such especially on the
undercards and unbelievably engaging
sport you can't look away yeah boxing is
only engaging at the most elite yeah
even when you watch the younger guys
they're just gonna Dominate and knock
the other guy out it's boring it's
boring it's like it's like it's too
one-sided and it's whack when you see
that high level chess match when you saw
what happened with Spence and Crawford
that is elite elite elite entertainment
and that's what the UFC can do the UFC
can match up Fighters that are on equal
levels and create interesting fights
with boxing since they're not all owned
by the same promoter or contracted by
the same promoter they can't risk it
you've got a young talented fighter you
can't risk them taking a loss so you put
them up against tomato cam for 20 fights
and then at the end of their career bud
is 35 arrows 33. like this is old for
boxing then they fight if this is UFC
they would have fought three times by
now before they're 30 years old
so you've seen them side by side really
exposes the advantages that the UFC has
yeah but I will say technical Elite
boxing is nothing's like so entertaining
it is so this was the first boxing match
I watched I was like oh this is like at
the time more entertaining than any of
the UFC fights yeah I mean it was and
there's an also an interesting racial
divide that happens because the second
that boxing match was over every black
person left the sports
every single Black Ops left the sports
yeah and so black people and and Latinos
but Latinos also like the UFC but black
people specifically are holding down
boxing yeah and that's why you see the
biggest fights are when you have black
Javonte Davis Bud Crawford Errol Spence
or Latino like uh who's the guy that
Javonte just beats Randy Ryan Garcia
Ryan Garcia like they are really holding
boxing together but in terms of like
white people in America they've really
kind of shifted over to uh UFC yeah yeah
that's a good one it feels like that is
it because they're not on a casual level
sorry on a casual the Casual fan yeah
the white casual used to be a white
casual box yeah now they're a White
Castle because they're not dominating
boxing at all like they're the whites
yeah they don't have they got Tyson Fury
but I don't know any other white box my
boy whites haven't dominated boxing in
about 200. but now they got an
alternative now they got UFC where it's
like oh we're still dominating seeing
yourself be reflected is always better
times this is like a cultural thing too
like if you don't hang out with a lot of
black people you might not know that
there's a boxing that might happen the
culture that you're like intertwined
with like if you're like a white dude
right who is uh into fitness and you're
listening to the most popular podcast
ever Joe Rogan you're hearing him talk
about your high level UFC fights and
you're seeing it like permeate the
culture that is outside of just
just boxing but just comedy culture
podcasting culture like think about how
much UFC talk there is yeah across
comedy podcasts yeah there's not as much
boxing and there's not as many boxers
that are coming in and like blending and
seeing that like we should have Bud
Crawford Bud should be here right now
they should see the value too like we
should have Javonte like their manager
should be like holy [__] yeah there's
been so many UFC fighters have been
built up through podcasting and through
these types of experience get them on
Rogan get them on flagrant get them on
these podcasts they could blow it up
that's true yeah why do you think
Crawford was so dominant curious balance
his balance his balance and timing I
think he's a harder puncher and he's a
faster puncher than Spence
and Spence has this like really
beautiful Relentless pressure that he
works behind the Jab
and he's got he's really interesting
um
fighter it's all working by the jab and
he does this great body work but he
couldn't get Crawford off balance and
Crawford was faster to the punch so like
when he would try to work him he
couldn't effectively get inside because
Crawford was catching him as he was
trying to come in so it was costly to
come in and the hands his hands Arrow
Spence's hands weren't heavy enough to
get Crawford to go I gotta cover up yeah
I think that's what made this I think
power made a difference nobody thought
that I was gonna be the case Crawford's
coming up from 135 Spence should
probably be at 154 by now he's a big guy
but for whatever reason but I heard uh
Crawford pretty much walks around at his
fighting weight and I think that's going
to be like Fighters are going to start
seeing like hey if there's advantages
yeah if you don't have to cut like that
like you can you're way stronger
debatable because you earlier in your
career when you can lose the weight in
the recover you you want to do that
because you're just so much more
powerful you're adding 20 pounds of
power on a punch you can add that the
next day what you lose sometimes is your
chin somebody's breaking this down on
the podcast but they're talking about
like the uh there's like a there's a
liquid barrier between your brain and
your skull blood blame blood brain blood
brain Berry but I think there's also
some like actual water and fluid that's
in that so the more dehydrated you are
the easier you are to knock out because
you just don't have as much of that
hydration separating your skull from
your brain that's what the guy said I
don't know how much truth is here at
this but they do say that that you can
be a little bit what's called chimney if
you're if you're really really
dehydrated but um you have an advantage
in power if you can come down I think
they sh if they can from all Combat
Sports they should remove like The
Cutting weight I that would be great I
think I shouldn't and the thing that you
notice with Crawford is it wasn't one
punch that was hurting them it was the
combination of punches right it was like
every time he could get up Arrow could
get up yeah but he just was gonna keep
getting battered yeah did you think
there was anything wrong with Errol
because that's what I'm seeing some
you think that's just selling a rematch
maybe I just from what I saw
Crawford's
Arrow's power wasn't significant enough
to make Crawford question his decisions
when he countered yeah even when he got
touched it would just like Snap him and
he was back like he never got wobbled he
never got disoriented at all yeah
because if you're a counter puncher and
you're not really worried about getting
hurt you can start taking some risks
yeah you can sit in the pocket you can
throw like there's that great moment
where Crawford knocked Spence down with
an uppercut on the inside so Spencer's
trying to crowd him remember that and
then he throws it you're only throwing
you're only throwing a front hand
uppercut
against a fighter that has been throwing
looping left hands if you're confident
that if that left hand lands you can
take it yeah this is a dangerous shot
you're throwing a looping left hand so
that means this hand is coming over the
top
yeah completely open uh you're only
throw on that if you're like I think I
can handle that power a couple of these
yeah
that's what it looked like I mean he was
I mean both of them to to spend his
credit but like both of them were
staying close yeah like the proximity
was right there it was beautiful man
like it was beautiful to see like two
dogs like both of them dogs and he stuck
it out more rounds than I thought I'll
be honest like after what the fourth or
fifth
time how many rounds did it go eight I
think eight yeah it just kept coming
forward man like that's so much respect
so much in the fifth round being like
what do you do like you're getting like
touched way more you can't like even
when you're connecting it's not actually
shaking them yeah like that must be such
a debilitating position of being mental
the doctor's coming out [__] checking
you and you're like yeah like the mental
roadblock to get through three more
rounds of that is 100 imagine that the
doctor comes in and says are you okay in
front of 20 000 people oh yeah but
twenty yeah yeah oh yeah exactly all the
people at home but like but both of them
are going to make life-changing money as
they deserve but is going to get the
credit that you deserve for the type of
boxer and the level boxer he is like a
lot of great things come from this yeah
if they fight again cool if not there
are tons of interesting fights for Arrow
you know what I mean like Arrow fighting
Ryan Garcia both coming off a loss yeah
both big names but has nobody to fight
now though Javonte now I don't think
Javonte will come up it's not going to
come up but that is what people would
love to watch
yeah I don't think but I don't even
think geronte should come up I think
Javonte probably naturally is a 135er
yeah so he's already coming up to 140.
but like there are there are people
there's the Charlo brother who's I think
at 154 and 160 but one you know maybe
they could find a catch weight like
there's some names out there what is he
what does Crawford normally fight at 147
okay what about uh Devin Haney Haney's
140. how about Shakur Stevenson I've
heard yes of course Stevenson I think is
140 as well but I think they're like I
think I think that's his mentor like
Shakur's mentors bud I obviously don't
know much but Matt McCoy our friend
comedian who did boxes was like Kyo
Shakur that guy could be he's got the
potential to be the best ever yeah
there's a guy named uh boots Ennis who
had a great outing that he might there's
a lot of guys in that uh that weight
class that that could be really fun and
interesting fights but yeah how much
credit do you give Eminem for the win
bro it was brilliant though because
Eminem is arguably the biggest superstar
in the history of rap in his day yeah
in any day like there isn't one sense
that's reached I am yeah I'm saying his
Peak versus anybody else's Peak was
there that's what I'm saying like so you
have the biggest superstar in the
history of rap walking you out right
now this doesn't feel like oh this is a
this is a specific cultural demographic
of boxing and black people that know
about this it goes all the white people
that didn't know who Bud Crawford was or
like Mae French knew see Eminem walking
out and they're like oh this must have
been a big fight I missed this [__]
funny if this is big enough for Eminem
to be there like what if I never walked
out anybody yeah it's like Jay-Z walking
out somebody yeah you'd be like what the
[__] this is a big deal bro if Jay-Z
walked out
Dustin Poirier or something uh what
would black people think about that UFC
fight yeah that's how I got right like
and I was like what a great strategic
move right there you know it wasn't even
strategic he just went on Twitter like a
couple days before he's like who wants
to walk me out yeah Eminem replied too
that's exactly and how cool yeah
so yeah anyway oh that's awesome fire
very cool fight and also shout out to
Dustin and Justin gaichi and uh yeah
what an amazing UFC card now yeah yeah
oh by the way if you want tickets to UFC
292 Sterling and O'Malley yes ufc.com
we're giving away two tickets and two
thousand dollars hit that up okay we'll
put the thing on the screen so everybody
knows but make sure you go do that go up
to Boston see that fight that fight will
be absolutely Sensational you know those
boys are gonna go at it
um yeah Dustin Poirier Justin Gates you
just engage you had just this
unbelievable game plan I mean doesn't
Poirier that I don't think gets enough
credit for having one of the sneakiest
defenses in
fight sports
like the way that he defends he has this
like great shell and he's really hard to
hit clean Okay and like but like he'll
I don't know he'll like he'll move his
hands he'll use like his elbows it's
like it's almost he he does like he has
like a almost like a Philly shell
elements of the Philly shell but he'll
also use it to block kicks and
everything that's really shell sorry uh
it's a how Floyd fights where it's like
one arm down use your left shoulder to
block right hands that are coming in and
then also your your uh right to Perry
Jabs okay anyway so he uses all these
things but he's really hard to hit flush
like if you notice it's rare that he
gets hit flush and even the kick that
Justin landed I've never seen Justin
throw a head kick in the entire time
that I've been watching him yeah he's
there like he blocks it with the right
hand but it comes and wraps around and
hits him on the back of the head so one
great strategic move by Justin his Camp
to go for a head kick when nobody would
expect that he would even throw that he
usually chews up your legs you know and
then uh two just just like great fight
both of them both of them great attitude
afterwards like tons of admiration for
one another like bro the backflip off
the cage how do you do like that's
insane yeah yeah just getting your leg
kicked
yeah yeah it's wild I mean just awesome
awesome UFC card shout out to poeton
Derrick Lewis is hilarious
that was so funny yeah that's my guy now
bro balls are hot first round flying
knee and just Pummel him who did he do
that to he fought some guy in covid and
just like walked him down 10 seconds and
just like destroyed him do you remember
this I can't remember who it was but it
was the same exact thing he just like
destroyed him and then same thing pants
come off immediately my balls is hot
yeah it's like the greatest and then
they asked him about it he's like I just
wanted to try some wild [__] to start
the fight yeah something like that no
real strategy like uh wasn't it Mosby
doll was like I saw there was a weakness
with ice cream that I could come at him
with this and he wouldn't be ready
Derrick Lewis was like man I just want
to try some [__] I lost a bunch of
weight I want to jump
you saw his absolutely you got the ABS
going I don't know it was just so
impressive that was a great fight I mean
awesome just like what we were so lucky
we got to witness that boxing card and
that UFC card at the same time yeah like
uh yeah we're so lucky yeah that was far
so lucky and enjoy it man and then the
Pereira block of its fight how was that
I didn't get to see you I thought it was
I thought poeton showed unbelievable uh
defense on the wrestling like his
wrestling and ground defense I mean if
you remember uh blahovich when he fought
Izzy yeah he didn't really try to attack
is he on the ground he just held him on
the ground which is I think more
difficult to counter when you're trying
to attack you risk putting yourself out
of position and someone can get out and
I think Jan was like if this goes to the
feet I'm at a major disadvantage against
Izzy because he's arguably the greatest
striker in the history of MMA so it's
like you you could but I think with with
uh with Jan and poeton I think he wanted
to try to see if he could get something
going on the ground he's like I think my
best chances are I can choke him out uh
and poeton was able to defend it I mean
I would love to see poton go win the
belt and then Izzy and him fight for a
third time for the belt at light
heavyweight Izzy becomes two division
champ and then if Izzy once challenge
Jon Jones at heavyweight and then three
division that's the big biggest fight in
MMA history and
we'll see what happens that's crazy yeah
and then he retires and becomes a rapper
forever dude oh that's fine yeah so
that's cool okay what else we got boys
all right Twitter's rebranded to X do
you want to talk about this yo Twitter
can do anything they want now that
threads is a dud
threads is over bro stop posting I
didn't think it's over it's over why do
you think it's over there's no culture
on it
there's no culture on it they didn't
offer anything new that we could create
culture around so it's just another
place to tweet and then potentially
dilute your content right so you're like
am I gonna do a Twitter thread am I
gonna do a tweet thread on threads and
then have to repeat this whole [__] on
Twitter that's too much it's kind of
like this there could be some work that
goes into a tweet you know you're like I
mean if you're one of these people that
do like long like 20 tweet threads like
that's a pain in the ass to repeat that
over on yeah threads when you've already
done it on Twitter it just didn't offer
a new thing it's like let's say you put
out a new iPhone there needs to be a uh
something seductive about the new iPhone
yeah I remember there was a time where
it was FaceTime it was a time where um
there was a three [__] cameras on the
outside and they had the super zoom you
just need to give me something that
makes me feel like mine is Antiquated
and I need to jump on right but it was
an exact replica of a thing that we
already have yeah I agree thread sucks
but I will say this in terms of Twitter
just doing whatever they want to they're
not competing with threads they're
competing with Instagram they're
competing with Tick Tock you know I
think we sell the thing he's trying to
make this like a WeChat One-Stop shop so
just because threads bomb doesn't mean
Twitter is going to win yes I mean it's
losing money been losing money yes so
how do you think elon's gonna make it
profitable is the X gonna help I don't
know I don't know this x thing is so
peculiar my feeling is like when it's so
bizarre and the move seems so out of
left field
I feel like I don't know what he's up to
he's up to something because it makes no
sense I can't tell if I'm gaslighting
myself but like I don't think he's a
stupid guy so when he's doing something
that makes no sense at all I'm like oh
there's a play here that's bigger than
he's like
in terms of I think what he wants to do
is create like a a financial uh backbone
as part of it right so
you can send each other money on it you
can maybe pay for things Etc he wants to
copy WeChat in China yeah oh is that
what we chat that that's what he said
yeah One Stop Shop you order food on
there you do everything on this one app
it's like an all-in-one app that like is
the most popular app in China literally
everything you can video call you can do
like voice text you can do Snapchat
basically you could do like moments like
Instagram stories you can do posting
content you can order stuff you can pay
with stuff you can do tap to pick like
everything is in this one app okay so
how does X work better with that system
I think it just becomes the app and if
it's the app it's profitable x marks the
spot next yeah oh how does the tower
like even the terminology like X me hey
can I can you buy some I'm gonna pay the
whatever yeah yeah just actually yeah
I'll exit and then I'll hit you back
yeah that's better I'll Twitter it I'll
tweet I think that's what he's up
against where he's like okay if this is
gonna become the One-Stop shop for
everything ever and all Commerce is done
under this app it has to be bigger than
just people are gonna look at him be
like oh that's the Twitter thing like
yeah like you I'm not yeah I'm not gonna
tweet money to you yeah does that like I
feel like they're dealing with the
Twitter is such good branding for what
it was and now he's trying to make it
into something what is XX is a variable
in my in math right so it's anything you
want it to be yeah yeah yeah it's just
it's he back in control because I
remember thinking about the CEO but the
he's also involved
yeah I know he's involved but is he back
the CEO of X now so it's like a
different thing um I'm assuming the CEO
is still the same time
yeah so that's what I'm assuming like I
don't all these people that are like oh
he's so stupid like I don't know if he's
stupid I love people calling you you can
call him stupid for things outside of
business like if you want to be like oh
you you spend 80 of your time or 90 of
your time at the office and you have all
these children and you're not as
involved in like their upbringing names
for your kids are stupid or exactly like
there's things
he wishes he wishes so I think those are
one of the things where like if you're
coming you know from someone who the way
that you value life is the time that you
spend with your family or with the
things that you're really passionate
about outside of building these
businesses you might be like oh it's
stupid to dedicate time in that way yeah
but to say that he's stupid for business
moves you got to be really smart to do
you got to have a lot of
you know I mean like like if Warren
Buffett was like yeah I think this is
stupid I'd be like all right let me hear
you out you know but average Twitter
user yeah that works for DHL is gonna
say that Elon is stupid for changing
into X without even knowing why yeah
what the thinking maybe it might not
work out the whole thing might go belly
up he might lose 44 billion dollars I
don't know that's to be seen yeah I
there is like an intentional plan to try
to level it up and take a huge like leap
to try to change the whole company and
everything that is admirable and
interesting will he get rid of the Eight
dollar paywall
because it's way more people are going
to use x if you can access everything
you need to access without a paywall
that's just life is the payoff just for
the blue checks or do they change it
paywall's just for blue checks but I
assume it gives you you can delete
tweets within x amount of time you can
you can do all these little things with
the blue check that you can't do without
oh I see yeah I think the refresh rate
you can only look at a certain number of
tweets without the blue check and then
with it you can not unlimited but it's a
way higher number so like there's all
these little limitations they're putting
on people who aren't paying eight bucks
a month I suppose people who are paying
eight bucks a month absolutely now if
you want this to be an all-in-one app
I'm not paying eight bucks a month to
venmo you I'm not paying eight bucks
you'll get into the transactions yeah
I'm sure it'll be something he'll get
his money in in the transaction like if
you're if you're buying food on it
you're doing all those things there's
going to be a little piece that comes
over to them and now they have more ways
to profit I think the issue with Twitter
right now is that you really can't
monetize it outside of ads and the
subscription yeah so the more things
that come up that are going to be usable
that they can monetize the less that I
think don't care about
[Music]
yeah it's like if you have a
subscription then we'll charge you less
transaction fees or no transaction fees
exactly maybe like like a YouTube uh
yeah Amazon Prime
yeah so 100